they see us the short stop
is 0-2 and a breaking ball just looped
into right field a base hit for iglesias
pilar and shadow right came up thinking
about a throw to first
but had no play now rio ruiz will bet
ruiz swings and drives one out to right
field while struck pilar
will watch it go rio ruiz
hits his second home run in as many
games
the orioles jump on the socks for two in
the first
well that's how you get the party
started how about you rui
out of the second two nothing oreos
here's austin hayes with two down
and he fits a little flare into center
field jackie coming hard dive makes
another sensational diving catch
he is amazing jbj
two outs nobody on bottom of the second
here's christian vasquez
high fly ball left field stuart looking
up
looking up and that ball is out of here
home run
christian vasquez will touch the ball
lifting that one high and gone
for his first of the year well just a
matter of time somebody's going to lift
one out here
top of the third inning orioles two red
sox one
iglesias line drive base hit into left
field this one's going all the way to
the monster
santander heading to third not a lot on
that throw
and santander will score the orioles
third run
on a double from jose iglesias finds the
barrel two-seam fastball left
square middle of the plate barrels it
out towards left center field two down
one on for chris davis and it's punched
out to shadowed up center field
in comes for dugo when he makes a
sliding catch
and this sliding grab by verdugo ends
the orioles chances
runners second and third for austin
hayes 2-2 pitch hayes swings
drives it out to center field going back
is bradley on the track
he makes the catch nunez tags from third
he scores as moving up an additional 90
feet is chance cisco
give hayes credit for a sacrifice fly
and the orioles lead as a field goal 4-1
now santander with two outs and a man at
third
that's hit well right field way back and
it is gone
into the bullpen and the orioles add two
more with more
clutch two out hitting this time anthony
santander
out of the house spot he's out in front
a little bit but he kept his hands back
and he went down
beautifully and put a barrel on this and
i mean just a
shot those bogarts come up with the
orioles leading by five
the 3-2 boguard swings hits this one
down the right field line starting to
slice on top derrick goes up
and makes the catch in the corner right
around pesky's pole
as he possibly takes a home run away
from xander bogart's
an incredible play by santondar the
orioles six the red sox won our score
we're in the bottom of the fifth
kevin pillar to lead it off for the red
sox
2-2 he'd go off that shot that one's
deep to left that's up there
and that ball is gone home run for kevin
pilar
he turned on it and golfed it out of the
ballpark so both of the red sox hit so
far
today our long home run yeah both moon
shots that ball was
down low around the knees he just almost
one
inch out of the ballpark here at fenway
park katie martinez next
the 0-1 is swinging a looper out to
right charging in
santa dare makes a diving catch
headed back to first is jackie bradley
jr
as santander who robbed a home run
earlier comes in takes a hit away
from jd martinez jackie bradley in third
raphael deborah's at second after double
slogarts hole for two in the ball game
today and the ground ball base set
jackie in to score rappy scoring as well
as he rounded third
that is a two-run single for xander
bogarts
as the red sox have jumped back into the
ball game 6-4
well you get the fastball here he leads
it on the inner half the plate and he
cleans it out of there
blinds the hole between short and third
and this takes a while to get the left
field
deborah scores all the way from second
base go to the bottom of the 8th jackie
bradley
swing ground ball left side and glacious
can't get it jackie with an opposite
field hit
he's been doing that consistently tying
run comes to the plate
round ball to third up and over to
second on to first trying to turn the
double play and out at first
base so they do turn two or that took
the air out of this inning that's double
play man
here's martinez each with their first
shorts up and a bobble bag laces and
will have no play and the sox
have another base runner well looked
like it was going to be out number three
but iglesias couldn't handle it here's
devers
and grounds that one a high hopper davis
will feed the pitcher
gets them plenty of time so nothing
doing here in the a still 6-4 baltimore
bottom of the ninth inning rodulgo has
to reach to extend it he's one pitch
away
0-2 and two out
upstairs good night everybody boom
orioles win the game
in the series to kick off the 2020
season